difficultés au sommet européen l'italie
et l'irlande à l'heure sous résidence et
dans l'europe monétaire
l'espagne à la veille du référendum sur
la constitution
bruno alba a pris le pouls du pays
alain colas toujours introuvable mais
les recherches continuent et tes proches
ne perd pas espoir
le tiercé en question c'est le procès
des courses truquées c'est aussi le
dossier de ce journal
mesdames messieurs bonsoir si c'est un
accouchement c'est un accouchement dans
la douleur il est encore trop tôt ce
soir pour vous dire si oui ou non
l'europe monétaire est vraiment né mais
nous ne sommes peut-être pas loin ce que
l'on sait c'est que cela ne se passera
pas sans convulsions dernières minutes
en pleine nuit valéry giscard d'estaing
disait son espoir de voir très vite mis
sur pied le système monétaire européen
le sm mais depuis le marathon a repris
les anglais puis les italiens ont fait
monter les enchères et puis plus
inattendus les irlandais qui demande un
délai de réflexion bref la discussion
entre les 9 et 13 autres et nous
attendons vivement que les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement sortent de leur salle
de travail à bruxelles pour avoir
quelques éclaircissements sur un dossier
déjà difficile heures soit environ 800
journalistes suivent ce conseil européen
la nuit dernière a été celle du premier
marathon des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement les nuits blanches de
bruxelles était jusqu'à présent réservé
au ministre il faut dire que l'enjeu est
considérable avec la création du conseil
européen en 1974 la naissance du système
monétaire est l'événement le plus
important pour l'europe depuis le traité
de rome a dit ce matin le président
giscard d'estaing beaucoup de rumeurs
circulent dans les couloirs tout à
l'heure on était assez pessimiste on
disait que l'irlande l'italie et
l'angleterre aurait décidé d'approuver
le nouveau système monétaire mais n'y en
aurait pas tout de suite bref ce serait
un système à six pays seulement il faut
dire que les mécanismes techniques
permettant de stabiliser les monnaies
implique des choix politiques chaque
pays devra suivre un véritable régime
pour empêcher sa monnaie de déraper bref
il sera un petit peu moins libres de
pratiquer la politique qu'il veut que
représenterait pour la france ce nouveau
système est bien les échanges
commerciaux facilité pour les
agriculteurs des prix plus stables la
possibilité de lutter plus efficacement
contre le chômage les grands équilibres
économiques étant rétablie on pourra
envisager des mesures de relance bref
lutter plus efficacement contre la crise
mais il y aura aussi des contraintes il
faut contrôler étroitement la hausse des
prix et des salaires il faut surveiller
de près la politique en matière de
crédit notamment les taux d'intérêt il
faut adapter les dépenses du budget aux
possibilités financières de la nation
bref il faut être prêt aussi à dépenser
de l'argent pour défendre le cas échéant
sa monnaie vous le voyez tous ces
discussions tous et tous ces problèmes
implique bien évidemment que les
discussions soient serrés parce qu'il
faudra ensuite expliqué aux différences
d'opinion publique dans chaque pays le
pourquoi des décisions qui ont été
prises à bruxelles antenne 2 voxel alors
je vous le disais en ce moment même les
neuf sont encore en réunion à tout
moment bien sûr philippe sassier et
maurice werther peuvent nous appeler
dans le courant de ce journal s'ils
sortent évidemment les pessimistes
diront que si les discussions sont si
difficiles à 9 elles le seront davantage
encore à 10 à 11 ou à 12 mais pour
l'heure les espagnols ne songe pas à
leur prochaine entrée dans le marché
commun ils pensent à leur propre
constitution demain en effet ils sont
appelés à se prononcer par référendum
sur cette charte 269 article résultat
d'un accord entre les principaux partis
politiques
la constitution très largement adopté au
parlement a été élaboré par des hommes
de tous bords d'un communiste à un
ancien ministre franquiste mais ce que
craignent les espagnols demain et bien
c'est davantage
l'abstention la différence que le simple
nom la seule véritable inconnue du
scrutin de demain c'est le pourcentage
de participation car si les sondages se
confirment neuf électeurs sur dix diront
oui au projet de nouvelle constitution
espagnole et le pays en terminera ainsi
avec le traumatisme de 40 années d'une
vie politique où les rapports de force
ont été des rapports de 21 ans a vaincu
hier soir en mettant un point final à la
campagne électorale à la télévision le
président du gouvernement adolfo suarez
a qualifiée de nouvelle fois le texte
sur lequel les espagnols devront se
prononcer demain de constitution de la
concorde
qui les grands partis ici le parti
communiste excentré avec adrian mais
aussi des socialistes les centristes et
la droite modérée ont également appelé à
bloquer affirmativement des centaines de
meetings ont été organisées au cours du
week end à travers toute l'espagne sans
toutefois déclencher les scènes
d'enthousiasmé spectaculaire qui avait
provoqué la campagne des élections du 15
juin 1977 c'est peut-être la conséquence
de l'adhésion de tous les courants
politiques du pays un même texte
adhésion générale à l'exception de
l'extrême droite et du pays basque où le
parti nationaliste recommande
l'abstention et l'extrême gauche aux
côtés à appelle à voter non ainsi le
pays basque sera-t-il demain soir malgré
une prévisible victoire écrasante du oui
dans le reste de l'espagne le seul vrai
point noir de la journée
l'iran maintenant s'il le veut il peut
rentrer en iran je vous jure qu'on ne
touchera pas qu'on ne l'arrêtera pas
voilà ce que viennent dire en début
d'après midi le premier ministre iranien
général azhari à propos de l'ayatollah
khomeini alors aussitôt de nos reporters
sont allés voir le chef de l'opposition
ligier dans sa retraite de neauphle le
château près de paris il n'a pas voulu
s'exprimer devant la caméra le
gouvenement français lui avait demandé
hier un peu de discrétion mais l'aura
fait dire qu'il n'avait de permission à
recevoir de personne qu'il rentrerait en
iran quand bon lui semblerait ce qui est
quand même un léger changement
d'attitude de sa part il avait jusque là
refusé de revenir à terre en tant que le
régime du chah serait pas encore en
place téhéran où visiblement de
nouvelles manifestations se préparent
comme l'on pouvait s'y attendre la
situation se dégrade de jour en jour en
iran à mesure que le mot haram le grand
deuil chiite avance la ferveur
religieuse en place la peur les
manifestations se font plus nombreuses
les iraniens n'hésitent plus à bras les
larmes et la loi martiale à descendre
dans la rue pour demander le départ du
shah ils le font même de nuit après le
couvre-feu ce soir par exemple comme
tous les autres soirs depuis vendredi
dernier en général quelques minutes
après le début du rassemblement les
soldats interviennent et c'est le reflux
des manifestants au beau milieu des
autres iraniens qui continuent à vaquer
à leurs occupations quotidiennes c'est
la situation que connaît téhéran depuis
le début du deuil chiite et cela risque
de continuer jusqu'au 12 décembre pour
la fin du mois rats d'ici là on peut
arriver y compris le départ du shah un
départ qui pourrait prendre la forme
d'un long voyage de plusieurs mois à
l'étranger c'est en tout cas une
hypothèse que l'on avance de plus en
plus souvent attire
un nouveau président pour le venezuela
monsieur herrera officiellement reconnu
vainqueur des élections c'était le
candidat de l'opposition il succédera
donc au président carlos andres perez
est ok rupture des relations
diplomatiques de l'egypte avec la
bulgarie et ce à la suite d'un presque
banal fait divers d'une querelle de
propriétaires et de locataires à propos
de l'immeuble de l'ambassade de bulgarie
au caire vietnam encore des centaines et
des centaines de réfugiés qui se ruent
sur les côtes de la thaïlande de la
malaisie et de formose 72 d'entre eux se
sont noyés au large de bangkok et 86 au
large de taiwan de formose et puis
algérie l'état de santé de houari
boumédiène est toujours stationnaire un
nouvel appareil français est arrivé à
alger à détecteur de bulles sanguine
cette prolongation de l'incertitude
permet quelque peu au conseil de la
révolution de s'organiser et de
commencer à préparer le futur congrès du
fln la première remarque que l'on peut
faire c'est que ce panégyrique de du
régime algérien depuis les 13 dernières
années apparaît aussi comme on sorte
d'adieu du conseil de la révolution à
houari boumédiène à preuve cette phrase
du communiqué qui rappelle que
l'objectif de la révolution algérienne
et l'édification d'un état capable de
survivre aux événements et aux hommes on
est très loin des butins de santé et
cette page du moudjahid ressemble
beaucoup à une écologie politique
au moins les choses sont elles
aujourd'hui clairement posée et les
algériens un peu plus bavard ces
derniers jours les algériens sont
prévenus la presse boumédiène ne
différera pas sensiblement de la
politique menée depuis 13 ans d'ailleurs
depuis quelques jours les organisations
de masse avait pris les devants en
lançant des mots d'ordre insistant sur
la préservation de l'héritage de houari
boumédiène une mise en garde à peine
voilée à l'opposition qui est réapparue
discrètement depuis la maladie du chef
de l'état algérien mais une opposition
disparates sans véritable assise
populaire et dans les tracts irrite plus
ces autorités algériennes qu'il ne les
dérange
toujours est il que l'accord politique
au sommet est maintenant acquis les 8 du
conseil de la révolution sont parvenus à
ton premier sont les points fondamentaux
de la succession de houari boumédiène
leur message le prouve de même que la
répartition des tâches opéré au sein du
conseil de la révolution même si cette
répartition est présenté comme
essentiellement provisoire
la paire française maintenant avec tout
d'abord une petite ébullition au sein du
rpr alain devaquet sur ce qu est un
général a rendu visite tout à l'heure à
jacques chirac qui soit 10 par
parenthèse devrait sortir de l'hôpital
cochin au milieu de la semaine prochaine
les deux hommes ont ré simplement évoqué
la décision de raymond barre de
poursuivre et de présenter lui même la
discussion sur le projet d'harmonisation
de la tva texte sur lequel vous savez le
gouvernement avait été battu la semaine
dernière il faut longue que le rpr
détermine l'attitude à avoir on a une
petite indication avec un vote en
commission des lois sur un autre dossier
vote au cours duquel les gaullistes sont
retrouvés en compagnie des communistes
bref la tension monte au sein de la
majorité d'autant que l'udf avait hier
réagi et s'est vigoureusement l'eau de
la baie le président du groupe rpr à
l'assemblée répété aujourd'hui qu'il
n'avait pas voulu avec son vote négatif
gêner le président a public avant le
conseil européen et qu'il avait été
choqué par les leçons données par l'udf
je m'arrête là mais on en reparlera
petite polémique aussi chez les
socialistes charles hernu a mis en cause
un sondage de la sofres qui vous le
savez était défavorable à françois
mitterrand par rapport à michel rocard
et l'ifop donne par l'intermédiaire du
provençal le quotidien de gaston
defferre un autre sondage ou là françois
mitterrand et michel rocard sont à
égalité de chance pour les
présidentielles mécha rocard qui par
ailleurs a déclaré aujourd'hui qu'il
jugeait tout à fait réalisable d'autres
politiques économiques pour la france il
l'a dit devant la presse économique et
financière
ce sera tout pour la politique
côté syndicats maintenant un tournant
peut-être dans les rapports entre la cgt
et la cfdt après le 42e contre l 40e
parlant concrète de georges cia a
grenoble les divergences subsistent a
constaté aujourd'hui edmond maire à
saint-etienne notamment sur l'europe
mais le leader la cfdt a jugé positive
l'ouverture la cgt
voilà canal
l'ensemble des raisons qui ont conduit
le bureau national a décidé de proposer
une rencontre à nos camarades de la cgt
nous croyons en effet que des éléments
nouveaux existent pour tenter un
ajustement de nos rapports unitaire
qui serait une aide au renouveau de la
pratique d'action de chaque
confédération
en tout cas nous sommes décidés à
rechercher avec nos camarades de la cgt
sans précipitation ni illusions
prématuré mais avec détermination et
continuité toutes les possibilités du
développement d'une action unitaire au
plus près les travailleurs sur des
objectifs qui correspondent à la période
où nous sommes
raymond barre devant le conseil
supérieur de la fonction publique qui a
réaffirmé l'attachement du gouvernement
la poursuite de la politique
conventionnelle
simone veil devant le conseil économique
et social cette fois a confirmé que le
gouvernement arrêterait dans les jours à
venir des mesures qui permettront de
réformer la sécurité sociale elle ne
dépare des favoriseront pas at elle dit
les industries de main d'oeuvre et ne
gêneront pas la compétitivité de notre
économie elle a rappelé aussi qu'il
n'était pas question de réduire le
niveau des prestations déjà servi aux
usagers encore des manifestations de
voyageurs la sncf d'abord gare de lyon
parce qu'un train avait pris 40 minutes
de retard et puis pour la même raison à
montfort l'amaury dans lés yvelines
enfin toujours à plouaret tu es dans la
région du trégor pour protester cette
fois contre la suppression de certains
arrêts dans cette gare nous vous avons
présenté un sujet là dessus dit manquer
le maire communiste de saint-etienne
reçu par le ministre de l'économie
rené monory un seul dossier entre les
hommes celui de manufrance n'ai pas de
déclaration à la sortie manu france où
edmond maire avait rendu visite et york
tél enfin la poursuite des discussions
entre le cnps et les syndicats à propos
de l'indemnisation du chômage d'orange
gratin de la neuvième réunion depuis six
mois sur ce sujet et le patronat a
laissé entendre ce serait la dernière
parce qu'ici le problème est urgent
alors le fond du problème précisé le
fond du problème c'est de rendre plus
rationnelle et plus juste le système
d'indemnisation du chômage dans une
situation où précisément le budget de ce
système est devenu très important du
fait du nombre des chômeurs alors au
bout toutes ces réunions les il ya quand
même un accord entre les syndicats et le
patronat sur plusieurs points sauf sur
un celui qui accroche c'est le problème
de l'allocation pour les personnes
licenciées pour motif économique
c'est-à-dire les 90% les 90 % voient
l'or parce que les positions des uns des
autres positions respectives alors aussi
bien patronat et syndicats s'entendent
pour dire que cette allocation devrait
être dégressive c'est à dire qu'une
personne qui est licencié pour des
motifs économiques devraient recevoir
plus au début de sa période de chômage
qu'à la fin ce qui n'hésiteraient plus à
trouver un travail mais par contre là où
il ya désaccord c'est le niveau laisser
les syndicats veulent partir de beaucoup
plus haut que ce que souhaite le
patronat ils veulent aussi favoriser les
boeufs salaires et le patronat déclare
que de telles mesures rendrait le budget
de la de l'indemnisation du chômage
impraticable étant donné qu'il ya déjà
un déficit qui se prépare alors si les
uns et les autres est sûre le provisions
qu'est ce qui s'est passé alors s'il ya
désaccord on peut imaginer qu'il y aura
peut-être quand même un délai de
réflexion et s'il n'y a pas de délai de
réflexion le gouvernement pourrait
prendre des mesures législatives pour
transformer le système d'indemnisation
du chômage or on n'en est pas là je vous
rappelle que pour l'instant c'est un
fait est fait et syndicats sont donc
toujours en réunion
chez nos voisins maintenant deuxième
semaine de grève dans la sidérurgie ou
est-allemand mais le conflit pourrait
rapidement peut-être se débloquer en
effet la puissante fédération de la
métallurgie accepté ce matin la
proposition du patronat de faire appel à
un médiateur
en dehors de la semaine de 35 heures les
30000 grévisse de ig metall 30000 sur 80
multi dirigiste réclament une
augmentation des salaires de 5% le
patronat lui propose une prolongation
des congés annuels à six semaines et une
augmentation des salaires de seulement
3% une enquête de notre envoyé spécial
en allemagne de l'ouest
michel meyer
les métallos de la ruhr sont dans la rue
depuis une semaine la grève touche un
secteur très sensible de l'économie
allemand les revendications des
syndicats sont tout à fait symptomatique
des préoccupations insatisfaction et
aspirations qui se manifeste sur la
scène sociale ouest allemand
en dehors d'une augmentation rituel des
salaires
les grévistes exigent aussi une baisse
de la durée hebdomadaire du travail à 35
heures
outre-rhin c'est la première fois que
cette revendication est soutenue avec
une telle insistance par des
syndicalistes très ferme avec le chômage
permanent allemand une des solutions
sera à 10 rue et de travail pour tout le
monde ça c'est la région pourquoi nous
demandons de 35 ans
au delà de l'agressivité verbale
affichée par les leaders syndicaux
devant leur base il n'y a pourtant pas
cette année encore la remise en cause
d'un consensus social allemand
naturellement trop légendaire pourrait
être totale
en fait les rapports entre les
partenaires sociaux se dégrade depuis
que les patrons répondent aux grèves par
le lockout autrement dit par la
fermeture pure et simple des usines ce
qui conduit les ouvriers à faire le pied
de grue devant leurs ateliers
le lock out c'est une manière de semer
la discorde entre les grévistes et les
non grévistes pour selon le patronat
faire face à l'irresponsabilité de
revendications comme la semaine de 35
heures
comme en france la cie diriger la
sidérurgie est dans une crise profonde
c'est justement dans cette industrie
quand vont commencer à appliquer la
semaine de 35 heures
sous le prétexte vouloir diminuer
le chômage on créera une nouvelle
pénurie au personnel qualifié sans créer
d'où nouvelles places travail il est
irresponsible des faire naître de faux
espoirs en affirmant
que l'on pourrait résoudre le problème
de l'emploi en réduisant le temps
travaille je suis très déçu monsieur
quand les syndicats n'ont pas sans
foulard et un tcc à dire pour le
changement de structure mondiale et pour
les problèmes la concurrence croissante
monial
en attendant et partant de réserves
financières leur permettent de payer les
grévistes comme s'ils travaillaient les
syndicats allemands ont les moyens de
poursuivre très longtemps leur mouvement
ne l'entendent patronales les touche
cependant très durement même si
l'industrie perd 100 millions de francs
lourds par semaine il reste que la
semaine de 35 heures est devenu ici un
objectif prioritaire on prévoit déjà
qu'elle sera réalité dès 1981 dans un
pays où il y a de plus en plus de
candidats à l'emploi est de moins en
moins de travail dans un pays où le
pouvoir syndical est un facteur
essentiel de la vie publique
malgré des ouvriers que rien ne fatigue
autant qu'une grève
les propositions à la les réactions par
non à la proposition de joël le tac
rouvrir les maisons closes deux femmes
politiques sont violemment contre
françois giroux et florence d'harcourt
le député du 16e gilbert gantier est lui
très peu juste un petit peu gêné par les
toiles d'araignées on commence à moins
divorcé en france en 1978 les demandes
en divorce n'ont augmenté que de 4% par
rapport aux 77 ce qui est inférieur à la
hausse habituelle quant au choix de la
procédure maintenant bien le
consentement mutuel représentent 40% des
demandes contre 30% l'an dernier les
tarifs de l'assurance automobile seront
rendus à la liberté le 1er janvier
prochain en fait depuis cinq ans il
n'existait plus de tarifs d'autorité la
direction des assurances se bornant à
examiner et à surveiller les résultats
des compagnies noël mamère nous en a
parlé
libération de pierre désiré a lair
l'entraîneur a quitté en début d'après
midi à l'hôpital de la prison des
baumettes s'il y avait été transformée
transfert est transférée par dont la
semaine dernière pour des soins pierre
désiré allaire a aussitôt regard et
grâce ceci même alors que le procès
bride abattue en est à sa 21e audience
aujourd'hui maître paul lombard et
armand serfaty plaidé pour le plus gros
des inculpés robert là où ira ce jockey
qui aurait entraîné plusieurs de ses
confrères à retenir comme lui leurs
chevaux pour le faire basson vouloir
d'aucune manière froissé l'intégralité
du fric dans l'homme qui dirige les
débats je dirais que ce procès d'abord
celui de la plage et six blocs est
bloqué par quatre questions première
question que veut dire que l'on barre
l'avocat de robert là où ira lorsqu il
s'écrit en pleine audience si je n'étais
pas lié par mon serment un certain
nombre de gens passeraient un mauvais
quart d'heure deuxième question qui a
procuré à 1 là où ira sans ressources
sans chômage les 22 millions de centimes
qui leur est versé aux jo qui corrompt
troisième question pour quelle raison
excellence j'en suis persuadé les
propriétaires les entraîneurs de chevaux
retenus ne sont ils pas portée partie
civile quatrième question pourquoi une
course ne t'elle pas annulée et paris re
porter lorsque quatre heures avant le
départ le pmu averti à plusieurs
reprises qui se passe quelque chose
d'anormal c'est étonnant tout le monde
patrick vous ne trouvez pas mais pour
répondre à une partie de ces questions
en tout cas nous allons essayer de
dépasser les murs de la 13e chambre
correctionnelle de paris et d'examiner
plus généralement le dossier de fierté
aussi des courses truc
le public de ce gigantesque procès huit
millions et demi de parieurs en france
les pièces à conviction l'enjeu 16 à 18
milliards de francs annuels jouer aux
courses la partie civile le pmu devant
un trop grand nombre d'enjeux anormaux
le paiement des paris est bloquée
jusqu'à résultats de l' enquête et puis
dans le box des accusés à un les
truqueurs et les tricheurs encore
trouverait
des chevaux qui mangent de l'avoine
enchanté des tocards qui gagne des
courses des favoris neutraliser des
enveloppes bourrées de billets de banque
dans les bottes des jockeys des fantômes
des morts des règlements de compte le
sco rifi cas depuis une quinzaine
d'années en france un parfum de scandale
la magouille des tricheurs éclate
aujourd'hui au grand jour hier les
trucages des prix de bordeaux georges de
talhouet 3 les brides abattues
aujourd'hui ceux de nîmes et de vos
frères les jockeys inculpés d entraîneur
en prison le monde du tueur est en
pleine ébullition
parmi les coupables le spécialiste du
trot hier désiré à l'aise entraîneur de
l'hiver des chevaux de plusieurs
vedettes dont sardou de long où mireille
da il avoué avant de quitter son seul
fils pour les murs froids d'une prison
que le monde des courses était à son
avis un monde pourri
c'est le système déconseille
complètement pourri on dit à des tâches
la une des tâches les bois abattus
aujourd'hui près de nîmes à marseille on
veut effacer les tâches on veut courant
fait condamner à hollwood river leur
enlever leur licence les met à pied à
ville pourquoi si l'intérieur est pourri
in you il y aura toujours des taches en
surface
l'intermédiaire présumés des truands et
cet ancien jockey robert là où r12
d'être du procès bride abattue
il est accusé d'avoir remis des
enveloppes au partant de ce grand prix
le 9 décembre 1973 à auteuil
interdit aujourd'hui de champ de courses
comme tous les inculpés de cette affaire
sans travail ni revenu il se fait tout
de même le luxe de s'offrir pour le
défendre devant la 13e chambre
correctionnelle de paris les services de
trois avocats dont un grand nom du
barreau
mise en cause par une dizaine de jockeys
dont cet ancien cravache d'or de
l'obstacle pierre costes qui montaient
ce jour là times square et qui a touché
20 mille francs pour tirer son cheval
robert lavéra prétend depuis le début de
ce procès qu'il n'a rien à voir avec
toute cette affaire pourtant aucun des
jockeys crack de ce prix bride abattue
n'était à l'arrivée de la course et pour
cause il avait transformé les favoris en
rat ou anciens comme on dit en argot de
tueur piste est-ce que vous avez vous
même touché des enveloppes à l'époque où
vous étiez jockey
je n'ai pas touché une enveloppe mais il
m'est arrivé de tirer un cheval
je crois que c'était une construite et à
cagnes sur mer d'ailleurs l'histoire
vous la raconter
une équipe décident de enfin je présume
l'équipe deux équipes décident de
truquer d'une course
la première équipe et sa distribution y
avoir dix huit partants rei 10 chevaux
la deuxième équipe à l'insu de la
première et sans savoir que la première
avait truqué
fait la même chose distribuer ra il dit
chômé comme par hasard par les mêmes
évidemment ce sont dix-huit partants il
y avait 18 chevaux qui tirait fadil
jacquin qui tiennent leur seul ou alors
je vous laisse imaginer la panique s
adonner personne ne voulait prendre le
départ trois faux départ après ça a été
une course de lenteur bien sûr et je
crois qu'ils ont pensé le pro tour alors
ralenti pour un ou quelques élus de le
rue de métier de jockey faut bien
d'autres n'empêche pour seul salaire à
la fin d'une course que les 150 francs
de la mode perdante et l'on court seule
décoration que leurs dizaines de
fractures jockey anonyme sous alimentés
pour ne pas prendre de poids ils sont
connus pour la plupart la vie des lacs
si certains en autriche et sur les
hippodromes les jockeys ne constituent
certainement pas le gros gibier du
milieu des courses des silhouettes plus
sombres sortie du trafic de la drogue du
racket dire tout de suite les ficelles
et les transforment temps marionnettes
je crois que c'est reparti
difficultés actuelles de la vie des
économies on arrive à avoir des
problèmes aussi bien sur les courses que
sur les jeux sur les casinos chaussée
ont fait qu'ils aient aussi bien passer
en angleterre en allemagne aux
etats-unis actuellement aussi
un peu de maladies la société peut être
on se souvient des gains fabuleux de
patrice de mutti ce qui avait ramassé
dans le prix de bordeaux par exemple en
1962 un demi milliard de centimes dans
1580 une combinaison depuis cette date
il est interdit de jouer plus d'un poids
la même combinaison tout cet étalage de
linge sale sur les hippodromes à son de
permis d'assainir les courses c'est tout
du moins l'opinion de françois poncet le
responsable de la société d'instituer
écoutez je prends d'abord que la sphère
du prix louis labatut a servi de leçon à
pas mal de gens dans la profession et
que les contrôles progresse ça déjà cinq
ans cette affaire-là et plus ça va plus
les contrôles film et
permettent si vous voulez
haut-commissaire d'exercer de façon de
plus en plus pointilleuses en mission
malgré le contrôle renforcé les
commissaires aux allures pour le trot
attelé
malgré l'oeil de la caméra qui suit les
courses de plat ou d'obstacles la boucle
est loin d'être bouclé seuls les jockeys
tricheurs ont pour l'instant été
démasqué mais les commanditaires se
dotant prononce craintivement les noms
sur les champs de courses les policiers
de la brigade des jeux ne sont pas
encore parvenus à les confondre
ce qui est certain c'est que à
l'occasion du prix de bordeaux en 1962
nous avons arrêté à l'époque un certain
nombre de gens qui appartenait aux
grands milliers
est-ce que depuis ces gens ont continué
à participer à des reconnaissances
courses truquées lankais jusqu'à
maintenant ne l'a pas démontrée mais
enfin il est vraisemblable qu'il y à une
organisation parce que pour truquer une
course il faut avoir des moyens
financiers importants et il faut
également disposer d'une certaine
structure pour pouvoir
26les établir les bordereaux les faire
valider un très grand nombre dans soit
l'échelon national lorsqu'il s'agit d'un
tiercé soit l'échelon de région
lorsqu'il s'agit d'un trio d'un tribun
triplé l'abcès est percé mais n'est pas
encore vidé 140 personnes sont
actuellement inculpés dans les
différentes affaires de courses truquées
mais pas de gros bonnets il y aura
bientôt du temps les surprises ce qui
rassurera les parieurs c'est que ce
scandale risquait de décourager à la
longue les joueurs les plus acharnés il
valait mieux le faire éclater au grand
jour en nettoyant taperont des écuries
c'était notre dossier du mardi soir un
dossier signé françois corner alain
colas toujours pas retrouvé la marine
nationale reprise ce matin ses vols de
reconnaissance les bréguet atlantique
compte à nouveau ratisser l'océan
recherche toujours aussi infructueuse si
les chances de retrouver rapidement cola
sont un peu compromise te raconte pas sa
compagne qui se trouve à [__] garde
encore confiance je crois dit elle il a
démâté 4 avion bréguet atlantique 2 à
pointe à pitre 2 aux açores ses avions
travail par investigations systématiques
à partir de leur point de départ
ces investigations ce fort se font sous
forme de quadrillage dans un faisceau où
les avions évolué de droite à gauche
jusqu'à une limite qui correspond
généralement à leur potentiel
il est certain qu'il y a pour l'instant
une zone d'incertitude dans laquelle à
part un vol de transit entre les açores
et pointe à pitre les avions n'ont pas
pu investiguer une façon systématique
donc c'est ce qu'on pourrait appeler le
trou du milieu représenté en
l'occurrence pour ce numéro 12 alors
hypothèse si le bateau d'alain colas se
trouve à cet endroit là on ne peut pas
leur père
pour l'instant si le bâtiment d'alain
colas manureva se trouve à cet instant à
cet endroit on peut penser que le bateau
va apparaître dans la zone
d'investigation des avions de pointe à
pitre
mais néanmoins il est depuis la demande
d'assistance officielle il a été lancé
des avis urgent aux navigateurs d'une
façon répétée des avis spéciaux qui
amène tous les bâtiments de commerce
d'état ou de plaisance à devoir signaler
de façon systématique tout ce qu'ils
pourront croiser et tout ce qu'ils
pourront voir
michel platini a retrouvé le stade sur
le terrain enneigé de nancy la
recommencer vous nous voyez à jongler
avec un ballon et même à participer à
une partie de tennis ballon avec ses
coéquipiers mois prochain il
accompagnera son club pour une tournée
au mexique débuts dans le championnat 28
janvier prochain en principe h de la
météo maintenant temps froid avec neige
nous sommes encore et pluie aujourd'hui
demain moitié nord un temps couvert et
douches des pluies sur le littoral
atlantique sur les régions de l'est un
temps froid du soleil près de la
méditerranée
23h30 ce sera l'heure de notre dernier
journal présenté par hervé claude vous
remercie de votre attention je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée l écoute
de nos programmes au revoir et à jeudi
demain vous retrouverez gérard holtz et
à 21h30 après le match de football